Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Let the word go forth from this time and place to friend and foe alike that the torch has been passed to a new generation of Americans born in this century
感谢收听《历史余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。让此时此地的声音传向远方，传给朋友和敌人，火炬已经传递给新一代的美国人，他们出生在这个世纪
tempered by war disciplined by a hard and bitter peace, proud of our ancient heritage, and unwilling to witness or permit the slow undoing of those human rights to which this nation has always been committed, and to which we are committed today, at home, and around the world. Let every nation know, whether it wishes us well or ill, that we shall pay any price, bear any burden, meet any hardship, support any friend, oppose any foe, to assure the survival and the success of liberty.
经受过战争的洗礼，受过严酷而痛苦的和平的磨练，为我们古老的传统感到自豪，且不愿目睹或允许那些人权受到缓慢的侵蚀——这些权利是本国一直致力于维护的，也是我们今天在国内乃至全世界所致力于维护的。让每一个国家都知道，无论它是希望我们好还是坏，为了确保自由的生存与成功，我们将付出任何代价，承担任何负担，迎接任何艰辛，支持任何朋友，反对任何敌人。
That, Dominic, was John F. Kennedy's inaugural address on the 20th of january 1961 did you enjoy that i do i thought it was pretty extraordinary so you said before you recorded that what were your expression i wasn't going to bother with precision it was about the vibe precision is for journey. Yes. Well, it's kind of like Picasso painting a bull or something. You get the sense of the bull, but you don't get the kind of absolute sense that it has four legs. You just have a sense of bullness. You do. Explain the pauses, the long Pinterest pauses. Well, if you watch it, he has incredibly long pauses. Ah, okay.
多米尼克，那是约翰·F·肯尼迪于1961年1月20日发表的就职演说，你喜欢吗？我喜欢，我觉得非常非凡。所以你在录音前说，你的表达是什么？我没打算纠结于精确度，这关乎氛围，精确度是留给旅程的。是的。嗯，这有点像毕加索画牛之类的。你能感受到牛的神韵，但你并没有得到它有四条腿的那种绝对感。你只是有一种“牛感”。确实。解释一下那些停顿，那些漫长的品特式停顿。嗯，如果你看的话，他有非常长的停顿。啊，好的。
Very, very long pauses. So I went through and I listened to it and I was struck incredibly long pauses okay very very long pauses so i went through and i listened to it and i was struck by those pauses because this is what we impressionists do right pick up on you know the little kind of hints of personality yeah things that make it distinctive that other people might not pick up on and i went through and i put a dash through that passage did you every time there was a pause well that is what sets the really top performers apart, isn't it? I like to think so. The attention to nuance and detail. I like to think so. But it's tremendous rhetoric, isn't it? It's great rhetoric written by Theodore Sorenson, Ted Sorenson, his speechwriter, who had been working for him since the late 50s.
非常、非常长的停顿。所以我通读并听了一遍，我被那些停顿深深打动了，因为这就是我们模仿者所做的，对吧？捕捉那些个性的小暗示，是的，那些让它与众不同的东西，其他人可能不会注意到的。我通读了一遍，每当有停顿的地方，我就在那个段落里加了一个破折号。这就是区分真正顶级表演者的地方，不是吗？我喜欢这么想。对细微差别和细节的关注。我喜欢这么想。但这确实是极好的修辞，不是吗？这是西奥多·索伦森，也就是他的演讲稿撰写人泰德·索伦森写的伟大修辞，他从50年代末就开始为他工作了。
Kennedy is a great phrase maker and he has a slightly sort of, I don't think he's the best speaker in the world, but he has this kind of declamatory style, slightly friends, Romans, countrymen style that I think works very well. It is. It's traditional oratory. Yeah. As opposed, say, to Reagan's more folksy. Exactly. Oh, kind of. Yeah, because JFK never really does folksy. He would probably regard that as too populist. He sees himself as the leader of the new
肯尼迪是一位伟大的措辞大师，他有一种稍微……我不认为他是世界上最好的演讲者，但他有一种演讲风格，稍微有点“朋友们，罗马人，同胞们”的那种风格，我觉得效果很好。确实。这是传统的演说术。是的。相比之下，比如里根那种更平易近人的风格。正是如此。哦，某种程度上。是的，因为肯尼迪从不真正走平易近人路线。他可能会认为那太民粹了。他把自己视为新罗马的领袖。
Rome. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So Tom, we are doing this series about the assassination of John F. Kennedy. And this week we're talking about the victim to try and sort of shed some light on why he might've been assassinated. Before we get into his presidency and how he becomes president, we should just recap a bit to reflect on the man and the politician so as a man i'm surprised how much i like kennedy having read up on him for these episodes because there's part of me that had always you know he's so boring because he's so ubiquitous you know it's like people who don't like the beatles because they're over familiar with the beatles yeah but actually the kennedy that i think emerges from the first let's say 40 years of his life, is actually a pretty likable guy. Charming, funny.
是的，完全正确。完全正确。所以汤姆，我们正在制作这个关于约翰·F·肯尼迪遇刺的系列节目。本周我们谈论的是受害者，试图阐明他为何可能被暗杀。在我们进入他的总统任期以及他如何成为总统之前，我们应该回顾一下，反思一下这个人及其政治家身份。作为一个男人，我很惊讶我竟然如此喜欢肯尼迪，因为为了这些剧集我读了很多关于他的资料，因为我内心的一部分一直觉得，你知道，他太无聊了，因为他无处不在，你知道，就像那些不喜欢披头士乐队的人，因为他们对披头士太熟悉了，是的，但实际上，我认为从他生命的前40年里浮现出来的肯尼迪，实际上是一个相当讨人喜欢的人。迷人，风趣。
Brave. Yeah, brave. Anglophile. I mean, what's not to like? Right. A big fan of Winston Churchill in North Melbourne. And somebody who had, as we know, most importantly, defended Stanley Baldwin in his book, While England Slept. Ticking all the boxes. He is ticking all the boxes. The one box that I think some listeners may be wondering about is the fact that he is so promiscuous and that he's not a faithful husband. I suppose the one thing I would say in defense of him, as it were, not that I think it's historians' jobs to attack
勇敢。是的，勇敢。亲英派。我的意思是，有什么不喜欢的呢？对吧。温斯顿·丘吉尔在北墨尔本的忠实粉丝。而且正如我们所知，最重要的是，他在他的书《当英国沉睡时》中为斯坦利·鲍德温辩护过。符合所有条件。他符合所有条件。我认为一些听众可能想知道的一点是，他如此滥情，而且不是一个忠诚的丈夫。我想我为他辩护的一点是，虽然我不认为历史学家的工作是攻击
or defend, he's not predatory. He doesn't have non-consensual relationships. He, without exception, has relationships with people who are very keen to have them with him. But also, we were discussing this in the previous episode. I mean, it's tied up with his daddy issues. It is. Because his father, Joe Kennedy, has basically taught his sons- That it's fine. That this is what you do. I mean, his father's a terrible father. Yeah.
或辩护，但他不是掠夺性的。他没有非自愿的关系。他无一例外地与那些非常渴望与他建立关系的人交往。但我们也曾在上一集讨论过这个问题。我的意思是，这与他的恋父情结有关。确实。因为他的父亲乔·肯尼迪基本上教导他的儿子们——这是没问题的。这就是你应该做的。我的意思是，他父亲是个糟糕的父亲。是的。
He lobotomises his oldest daughter, Rosemary. Yeah, exactly. In 1940, was it, or something? An absolutely tragic story. So Rosemary had what we would now call severe learning difficulties, and the family decides, or Joe decides, we don't really know how much his wife was involved with the decision. He's persuaded by people he talks to, surgeons on Cape Cod or whatever, that the thing to do is to have her sent for a lobotomy and that destroys her life effectively that's a terrible mistake to have made it's not necessarily his fault he's following the advice well yeah it's a ghastly story tom it's an
他对他最大的女儿罗斯玛丽进行了脑叶切除手术。是的，完全正确。是在1940年，还是什么的？一个绝对悲惨的故事。所以罗斯玛丽有我们现在所说的严重学习障碍，而家庭决定，或者乔决定，我们真的不知道他妻子在多大程度上参与了这个决定。他被他交谈过的人，科德角的医生什么的，说服了，认为应该做的事是送她去做脑叶切除手术，这实际上毁了她的一生。这是一个可怕的错误。这不一定是他的错，他是在听从建议。嗯，是的，这是一个可怕的故事，汤姆，这是一个
absolutely ghastly story but anyway he's he's not a good father no he's not and maybe you could say about jfk that what's incredible is he turns out as well-adjusted as he does. I think that's actually a reasonable thing to say. We reflected on the man, just reflect on the politician for a second, because I think understanding the politician is really important when we get into the theories about why he was murdered. At the point that we ended last time, the late 1950s, he is an extremely conventional politician. He is not on the left of the Democratic Party. He is kind of squarely in the middle. So he's from Massachusetts. That means he's almost automatically more liberal
绝对可怕的故事，但无论如何，他不是一个好父亲。不，他不是。也许你可以说关于肯尼迪，令人难以置信的是他竟然变得如此适应良好。我认为这实际上是一个合理的说法。我们反思了这个人，再反思一下这位政治家，因为我认为当我们进入关于他为何被谋杀的理论时，理解这位政治家非常重要。在我们上次结束的时候，即1950年代末，他是一位极其传统的政治家。他不在民主党的左翼。他处于中间位置。所以他来自马萨诸塞州。这意味着他几乎自动地比许多人更自由
than many because Massachusetts is a very liberal state, an urban state, big unions, all that kind of thing. So he's not going to be a big defender of segregation. It'd be unthinkable for a senator from Massachusetts to be a defender of segregation, for example. And he's not going to be a big defender of segregation it'd be unthinkable for a senator from massachusetts to be a defender of segregation for example and he's not an isolationist or anything like that but there's nothing about jfk at this point that would alarm people you know unless you're the kind of person who thinks all democrats and marxists and there are people like that yeah but business leaders other politicians you know even sort of southern democrats or republicans in congress they've seen plenty of people like him before you know he's not as left other politicians, even sort of Southern Democrats or Republicans in Congress. They've seen plenty of people like him before. He's not as left-wing as FDR was, for example.
因为马萨诸塞州是一个非常自由的州，一个城市化的州，有大工会，诸如此类。所以他不会成为种族隔离的坚定捍卫者。例如，对于马萨诸塞州的参议员来说，成为种族隔离的捍卫者是不可想象的。他也不是孤立主义者之类的，但此时的肯尼迪没有任何会让人们感到惊慌的地方，你知道，除非你是那种认为所有民主党人都是马克思主义者的人，确实有那样的人，是的，但商业领袖、其他政治家，你知道，甚至是国会中的南方民主党人或共和党人，他们以前见过很多像他这样的人，你知道，他不像富兰克林·罗斯福那样左倾。
So this presumably makes him an ideal person to run for the presidency. Absolutely. I mean, he's the kind of figure that the Democrats at the moment are signally lacking. Yes. Because the Kennedy that's floating around now believes all kinds of mad stuff, doesn't he? Yes, Robert Kennedy's son. Ali now believes all kinds of mad stuff, doesn't he? Yes, Robert Kennedy's son. Aliens and all kinds of stuff. Exactly.
所以这大概使他成为竞选总统的理想人选。绝对。我的意思是，他是民主党目前明显缺乏的那种人物。是的。因为现在到处流传的肯尼迪相信各种疯狂的东西，不是吗？是的，小罗伯特·肯尼迪。阿里现在相信各种疯狂的东西，不是吗？是的，小罗伯特·肯尼迪。外星人什么的。完全正确。
But JFK is straight down the road, bang on the nail, centrist, exactly what you want if you want to win an election. Especially in an age, Tom, when the two big parties are uneasy coalitions. They're regional coalitions rather than ideological. But they always are, aren't they? They are. But in this period, to win, the Democrats must win urban, northeastern kind of cities and things. So the Chicago's, the Boston's, New York's and so on. Ideally, they'd like to win California
但肯尼迪是直截了当的，正中要害，中间派，如果你想赢得选举，这正是你想要的。特别是在一个时代，汤姆，当两大政党都是不安的联盟时。它们是区域性联盟，而不是意识形态联盟。但它们总是这样，不是吗？它们是。但在这一时期，要获胜，民主党必须赢得城市、东北部之类的城市。所以芝加哥、波士顿、纽约等等。理想情况下，他们想赢得加利福尼亚
and they would also need to win the white segregationist South where a lot of black people can't vote. So in other words, if you nominate somebody who is a fervent champion of black people can't vote. So in other words, if you nominate somebody who is a fervent champion of black civil rights, you will alarm white Southern voters and you will forfeit the support of the kind of white Southern power brokers. But conversely, presumably, if you are
他们还需要赢得白人种族隔离主义的南方，那里很多黑人不能投票。所以换句话说，如果你提名一个黑人权利的坚定拥护者，你就会惊动南方白人选民，你就会失去南方白人权力掮客的支持。但反过来，大概，如果你
very associated with the segregationist traditions, then you're not going to win liberals in the Northeast. Correct. Exactly. Exactly so. Yes, I see. Yes. It's a coalition and it's a tough ask. And if you've got a young war hero with a very beautiful wife, a young family, loads of money, lots of glamour, then you're laughing. And so when Kennedy announced that he's standing, which is in January 1960, he's obviously going to be very hard to beat. There are two downsides. One, senators don't normally win.
与种族隔离主义传统联系太紧密，那么你就赢不了东北部的自由派。正确。完全正确。是的，我明白了。是的。这是一个联盟，这是一个艰巨的任务。如果你有一个带着漂亮妻子的年轻战争英雄，一个年轻的家庭，大量的金钱，很多的魅力，那么你就稳操胜券了。所以当肯尼迪宣布他要参选时，那是在1960年1月，他显然很难被击败。有两个缺点。第一，参议员通常不会赢。
So it's very rare for a senator to get the nomination because senators are kind of seen as legislators. They're not executives. And secondly, he's a Catholic. And America's never had a Catholic president. There has been a Catholic candidate for president, Al Smith, in 1928. But he was hammered by Herbert Hoover. So that kind of hangs over Kennedy. Can he beat the wasps? Can he beat the wasps? And he has to prove himself by doing something that a lot of
所以参议员获得提名是非常罕见的，因为参议员被视为立法者。他们不是行政人员。其次，他是个天主教徒。美国从未有过天主教总统。1928年曾有一位天主教总统候选人，阿尔·史密斯。但他被赫伯特·胡佛击败了。所以这笼罩着肯尼迪。他能打败那些盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒（WASP）吗？他能打败WASP吗？他必须通过做很多事情来证明自己
candidates don't bother doing. He enters the presidential primaries. So we now think of presidential primaries as the norm, but they were quite exceptional in those days. Lots of people didn't enter and thought they could kind of set up the nomination at the convention. So he enters the primaries and he wins in two quite Protestant states. So Wisconsin and West Virginia, they're the two big tests. He beats the local favourite, who's Hubert Humphrey from Minnesota. And in doing so, he shows that Catholics can win elections outside their own kind of heartland.
候选人懒得做的事。他参加了总统初选。我们现在认为总统初选是常态，但在那个年代它们非常特殊。很多人没有参加，认为他们可以在大会上搞定提名。所以他参加了初选，并在两个相当新教的州获胜。所以威斯康星州和西弗吉尼亚州，这是两个大考验。他击败了当地的热门人选，即来自明尼苏达州的休伯特·汉弗莱。通过这样做，他证明了天主教徒可以在他们自己的核心地带之外赢得选举。
And how much kind of anti-Catholic sentiment is there floating around his candidacy? Is he going to be ruled from Rome and all that kind of thing? There's a fair bit of talk of this. I think most Americans actually don't think this way at all. There are always a few who do, because there's still a fair bit of kind of sectarianism, but most Americans don't. I mean, Kennedy puts that to bed quite successfully. But I think because it had never happened, he's always being asked about it. I mean, it seems mad now, looking back, that in 1960, the candidates for the Democratic Party was having to go around making speeches about his belief in the separation of church and state. Someone to go out of his way to say he believed in the separation of church and state and that he would not be dictated to by Rome.
那么他的候选资格周围有多少反天主教情绪？他会被罗马统治之类的吗？有很多关于这个的讨论。我认为大多数美国人实际上根本不这样想。总有一些人会这样，因为仍然存在相当多的宗派主义，但大多数美国人不会。我的意思是，肯尼迪相当成功地平息了这一点。但我认为因为从未发生过，他总是被问到这个问题。我的意思是，现在回想起来，1960年民主党的候选人不得不四处发表演讲，谈论他相信政教分离，这看起来很疯狂。有人不得不特意说他相信政教分离，并且他不会被罗马所左右。
That all dates back to Gregory VII, the famous Pope of the 11th century. So a historical irony there. Well, this is a lovely teaser, Tom, for your forthcoming episodes, which you would be doing in 2029, did we agree? To be discussed. On Gregory VII. Anyway, he goes to the convention. He wins on the first ballot. There are lots of other candidates. So Lyndon Baines Johnson, the Senate majority leader, Democrat, kind of Texan, is one of the other candidates. And Kennedy actually ends up picking him as his vice presidential nominee.
这一切都可以追溯到11世纪著名的教皇格列高利七世。所以这里有一个历史讽刺。嗯，这是一个可爱的预告，汤姆，为你即将到来的剧集，我们约定是在2029年做吗？待讨论。关于格列高利七世。无论如何，他去了大会。他在第一轮投票中获胜。还有很多其他候选人。所以林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊，参议院多数党领袖，民主党人，德克萨斯人，是其他候选人之一。肯尼迪最终确实选择了他作为他的副总统提名人。
And that's to balance his Northeast kind of liberal Harvard, Massachusetts vibe with a hard drinking, hard pissing Southerner. Right. Yes, a Texan. So not somebody from the real heartland, the segregationist heartlands of Mississippi, South Carolina or somewhere, but a Texan. So on the kind of fringes of the South, but somebody who knows how to work the system in Congress. Somebody who's been around a lot. I mean, they're a very odd couple. They have nothing in common, but it's a sensible choice. And Kennedy makes this grand speech at the convention about the new frontier. You know, we stand on the frontier of the 1960s.
那是为了平衡他东北部那种自由派哈佛、马萨诸塞州的氛围，和一个酗酒、粗鲁的南方人。对。是的，一个德克萨斯人。所以不是来自真正的核心地带，密西西比、南卡罗来纳或其他地方的种族隔离核心地带，而是一个德克萨斯人。所以是在南方边缘，但知道如何在国会运作系统的人。一个阅历丰富的人。我的意思是，他们是一对非常奇怪的组合。他们没有任何共同点，但这是一个明智的选择。肯尼迪在大会上发表了关于新边疆的宏大演讲。你知道，我们站在1960年代的边疆。
He appeals to youth. He says, my call is to the young at heart, regardless of age. The Cold War is crucial for him. So he says, you know, we're in a struggle for mastery, a race for mastery of the sky and the rain, the oceans and the tides, the far side of space and the inside of men's minds. This is the kind of soaring rhetoric that I think if somebody did now in the 21st century, people would slightly laugh. But in 1960, people would love it. I mean, they did love it. I don't know. I think someone should try it. Can you see Rishi Sunak coming out with this, Tom?
他呼吁年轻人。他说，我的呼吁是给那些年轻的心，无论年龄大小。冷战对他来说至关重要。所以他说，你知道，我们正处于一场争夺主导权的斗争中，一场争夺天空和雨水、海洋和潮汐、太空远端和人类思想内部主导权的竞赛。这是一种高昂的修辞，我想如果现在21世纪有人这么做，人们会稍微嘲笑。但在1960年，人们会喜欢它。我的意思是，他们确实喜欢它。我不知道。我认为有人应该尝试一下。你能想象里希·苏纳克说出这些话吗，汤姆？
No, not Rishi. Someone in America. Yeah, maybe. So he goes into the general election and he's up against Nixon, the vice president. With his five o'clock shadow. With his five o'clock shadow. That's been massively overstated, you know. So this is a reference to the TV debate. Nixon wore a pale suit and kind of looked very haggard. Sweaty.
不，不是里希。美国有人。是的，也许。所以他进入了大选，他面对的是副总统尼克松。带着他的五点钟胡茬。带着他的五点钟胡茬。那被严重夸大了，你知道。所以这是指电视辩论。尼克松穿了一套浅色西装，看起来非常憔悴。出汗。
He did look sweaty because he said he was going to visit every single state to show his dynamism. So he'd visited every single state and he was absolutely exhausted. And he'd also hurt his knee and then been hospitalized. And he drags himself from his hospital bed to do this debate. And actually, I mean, there's sort of one clip of him looking a little bit sweaty. He's not even looking that sweaty. He's looking a tiny bit sweaty. And that's now become a staple of documentaries. But actually, if you watch the whole debate, it's actually very
他确实看起来出汗了，因为他说他要访问每一个州以展示他的活力。所以他访问了每一个州，他绝对精疲力竭。而且他还伤了膝盖，然后住院了。他从病床上爬起来参加这场辩论。实际上，我的意思是，有一个片段显示他看起来有点出汗。他甚至看起来没那么出汗。他看起来有一点点出汗。而这现在已经成为纪录片的素材。但实际上，如果你看整个辩论，它实际上非常
boring. They're both really good by modern standards. I mean, you watch it in disbelief at how far the standards have plummeted since then. They're both very articulate, really well informed, very thoughtful. They don't really disagree on very much. The big issue is Kennedy says, under the Eisenhower administration, we've fallen behind the Soviet Union. They don't really disagree on very much. The big issue is Kennedy says, under the Eisenhower administration, we've fallen behind the Soviet Union. They sent up a Sputnik satellite in 1957. Fidel Castro has come to power in Cuba in the Cuban revolution. And also Kennedy says there's this massive missile gap. He goes on about this all the time. He says the Russians have so many more missiles than we do. So in a way, he's attacking Nixon from the right.
无聊。按现代标准来看，他们俩都非常好。我的意思是，你看着它，不敢相信自那时以来标准已经下降了多少。他们俩都非常善于表达，消息灵通，非常深思熟虑。他们对很多事情并没有真正的分歧。最大的问题是肯尼迪说，在艾森豪威尔政府下，我们已经落后于苏联了。他们对很多事情并没有真正的分歧。最大的问题是肯尼迪说，在艾森豪威尔政府下，我们已经落后于苏联了。他们在1957年发射了人造卫星。菲德尔·卡斯特罗在古巴革命中上台。而且肯尼迪还说存在巨大的导弹差距。他一直都在说这个。他说俄罗斯人拥有的导弹比我们多得多。所以从某种意义上说，他是在从右翼攻击尼克松。
Yeah. If you want to see it that way, I mean, I wouldn't describe it in left-right terms, but absolutely. He says they're stagnant, conservative, and they've done nothing. And they've fallen behind in the Cold War. And I will prosecute the Cold War with great dynamism and vigour. And we'll have shiny rockets. And we'll go to space. And we'll do all of these exciting things. When does he give his pledge to get a man on the moon? So that's 1961 later. But it's kind of incubating there. Oh, absolutely. So when Gagarin is the first man into orbit, Kennedy, his response to that is to
是的。如果你想那样看的话，我的意思是，我不会用左右派的术语来描述它，但绝对是。他说他们停滞不前，保守，什么都没做。他们在冷战中落后了。我将以巨大的活力和精力来推进冷战。我们将拥有闪亮的火箭。我们将进入太空。我们将做所有这些令人兴奋的事情。他什么时候承诺要把人送上月球？那是1961年晚些时候。但这在某种程度上已经在酝酿了。哦，绝对。所以当加加林成为第一个进入轨道的人时，肯尼迪对此的回应是
say, we will get somebody on the moon by the end of the decade. So this is all part of his kind of new frontier thing. You can understand why he's saying this, because America has had... It's not perfect, of course. It's had McCarthyism and the civil rights issue. But America is by far the richest, most affluent, most technologically advanced country on Earth. Tremendous optimism around, we can do what we want. We can put a man on the moon. We can solve poverty. We can win the Cold War. Kennedy is the embodiment of that early 60 60s kind of shiny space age, atomic age optimism. But also Camelot, famously, is the word that's applied to his White House. Though only afterwards, Tom.
说，我们将在十年结束前把人送上月球。所以这都是他那种新边疆的一部分。你可以理解他为什么这么说，因为美国已经……当然，它并不完美。它有麦卡锡主义和民权问题。但美国是迄今为止地球上最富有、最富裕、技术最先进的国家。周围有巨大的乐观情绪，我们可以做我们想做的。我们可以把人送上月球。我们可以解决贫困。我们可以赢得冷战。肯尼迪是60年代早期那种闪亮的太空时代、原子时代乐观主义的化身。但卡米洛特（Camelot）也是，著名地，这是应用于他白宫的词。尽管是在之后，汤姆。
Oh, not at the time. So it's actually Jackie giving an interview to Life magazine, I think months after his assassination, says, oh, it was like Camelot. We love Camelot because they loved the musical. Yes. They're very much a musical. So when people go on about the glamour of the Kennedy White House. What is it? What do the common people do?
哦，不是当时。所以实际上是杰基在接受《生活》杂志采访时，我想是在他遇刺几个月后，说，哦，那就像卡米洛特。我们喜欢卡米洛特，因为他们喜欢那部音乐剧。是的。他们非常喜欢音乐剧。所以当人们谈论肯尼迪白宫的魅力时。那是什么？普通人做什么？
I think they sing. That's it. Yes. Yeah. I can't remember how it goes, but they're very much people who like listening to Broadway musicals and sipping martinis. That's their kind of mad men. Yes. Yeah. And that's the sort of Camelot mystique.
我想他们唱歌。就是这样。是的。是的。我不记得它是怎么唱的，但他们是非常喜欢听百老汇音乐剧和喝马提尼酒的人。那是他们的那种“广告狂人”。是的。是的。这就是那种卡米洛特神秘感。
Now, actually, the interesting thing is we've listed all candidates' great advantages and assets. This is the closest election in modern American history. Both candidates win just over 49.5% of the vote and actually goes to two states, Illinois and Texas. And in both of those states, there were allegations that it had been fixed and there'd been fraud and that people had stuffed boxes. Right, because the allegation that Joe Kennedy bought the presidency for his son, it's a kind of Trump-esque complaint, isn't it, that rumbles throughout his presidency. And it plays a part in the theories after Kennedy's death, because some people
现在，实际上有趣的是，我们列出了所有候选人的巨大优势和资产。这是现代美国历史上最接近的选举。两位候选人的得票率都略高于49.5%，实际上取决于两个州，伊利诺伊州和德克萨斯州。在这两个州，都有指控称选举被操纵了，存在欺诈，人们塞满了票箱。对，因为乔·肯尼迪为他儿子买下总统职位的指控，这是一种特朗普式的抱怨，不是吗，这在他整个总统任期内都在流传。这在肯尼迪死后的理论中起了一定作用，因为有些人
listening to this may well say, they fixed the election, Joe Kennedy bought the election, but he didn't deliver, and then the mafia killed him. Okay, so let's bear that in mind. Well, the truth of the matter, just on that election, he didn't buy the election. They did spend a lot of money, but was there a sense in 1960 that it had been fraudulently bought? Not really. And also, it's possible that there'd been a little bit of ballot box stuffing in Illinois. The margin there was 9,000 votes. But in Texas, the margin is 46,000 votes. That's a hell of a lot of votes.
听到这里可能会说，他们操纵了选举，乔·肯尼迪买下了选举，但他没有兑现，然后黑手党杀了他。好吧，让我们记住这一点。嗯，事实是，关于那次选举，他没有买下选举。他们确实花了很多钱，但在1960年有一种选举被欺诈性买下的感觉吗？并没有。而且，伊利诺伊州可能确实有一点塞票箱的情况。那里的差距是9000票。但在德克萨斯州，差距是46000票。那可是相当多的票。
So most academics, in fact, almost all academics, I think, who have looked into this say that was not a stolen election. You know, actually, there's always a little bit of grey area in some of these things because local election officials, yeah, they make mistakes, they are appointed by the party, they maybe, you know, lean one way or the other, but this isn't a case of major fraud by any means. So Dick Nixon slinks off to lick his wounds
所以大多数学者，事实上，几乎所有研究过这个问题的学者，都说那不是一场被窃取的选举。你知道，实际上，在其中一些事情中总有一点灰色地带，因为当地选举官员，是的，他们会犯错，他们是由政党任命的，他们可能，你知道，倾向于某一方，但这绝不是大规模欺诈的情况。所以迪克·尼克松溜走去舔他的伤口
and Kennedy, meanwhile, is preparing to deliver his long pause- strewn inaugural address he is indeed now on his administration Tom this is again important when we come to the murder a common belief among conspiracy theorists is that Kennedy was ultimately much more left-wing than people realized that he's a radical who is going to alter American foreign policy or domestic policy in some alarming way. And for that reason, he had to be eliminated. When you look at the people in his administration, the key players, they're all very much the old kind of Washington insiders. So his Secretary of State, Dean Rusk, had been a State Department official in the 1950s, and then he had run the
而肯尼迪，与此同时，正准备发表他那充满长停顿的就职演说。他确实如此。现在谈谈他的政府，汤姆，当我们谈到谋杀时，这一点再次很重要。阴谋论者中一个普遍的信念是，肯尼迪最终比人们意识到的要左倾得多，他是一个激进分子，将以某种令人震惊的方式改变美国的外交政策或国内政策。因此，他必须被清除。当你看看他政府中的人，关键人物，他们都是非常老派的华盛顿内部人士。所以他的国务卿迪恩·腊斯克，在1950年代曾是国务院官员，然后他经营了
Rockefeller Foundation. His treasury secretary, Douglas Dillon, was an Eisenhower Republican, had been an Eisenhower official. And his defense secretary, Robert McNamara, had worked for the Air Force, and then he had been head of the Ford Motor Company. So these are not firebrand radicals by any stretch of the imagination. they are very establishment figures very military industrial complex so dominic they are very military industrial complex but is kennedy himself not somebody who would be military industrial complex adjacent to tom people who've watched oliver stone's film jfk will remember that it opens with eisenhower
洛克菲勒基金会。他的财政部长道格拉斯·狄龙，是一位艾森豪威尔共和党人，曾是艾森豪威尔的官员。他的国防部长罗伯特·麦克纳马拉，曾为美国空军工作，然后是福特汽车公司的负责人。所以这些绝不是激进的煽动者。他们是非常建制派的人物，非常军工复合体。所以多米尼克，他们是非常军工复合体，但肯尼迪本人不是那种会与军工复合体相邻的人吗？汤姆，看过奥利弗·斯通电影《刺杀肯尼迪》的人会记得，它以艾森豪威尔
in his last broadcast warning against the military industrial complex, doesn't he? So I just throw that out. Which he absolutely did. But I think Eisenhower's warning there is partly a warning actually about let's not overspend. Let's not throw loads of money at expensive military white elephants just to please big business and their friends in the military who want to build air bases and stuff everywhere and waste everybody's money. I think this sort of the idea that Eisenhower is actually secretly, Dwight Eisenhower hated the United States and
在最后一次广播中警告军工复合体开始，不是吗？所以我只是提一下。他确实这样做了。但我认为艾森豪威尔在那里的警告部分实际上是一个警告，让我们不要过度支出。让我们不要为了取悦大企业和他们在军方中想要到处建造空军基地并浪费大家钱的朋友，而把大量的钱扔在昂贵的军事白象工程上。我认为这种认为艾森豪威尔实际上是秘密地、德怀特·艾森豪威尔憎恨美国和
its mission in the world. I mean, that's obviously nonsense. Eisenhower is incredibly patriotic and has already toppled a government in Guatemala, Tom, in 1954. All right, Poirot. Carry on with your account of the murderese administration, stacking up the clues or not so it's possible i suppose that somebody might want to murder kennedy because they regarded him as too left-wing domestically it's possible but is it likely so if you look at his economic policy that's the thing that most people usually care most about not the most eye-catching but if you ask ordinary people it's bread and butter stuff.
它在世界上的使命的想法。我的意思是，这显然是无稽之谈。艾森豪威尔非常爱国，而且已经在1954年推翻了危地马拉政府，汤姆。好吧，波洛。继续你对谋杀政府的描述，堆积线索或者不堆积。所以我想有人可能想谋杀肯尼迪，因为他们认为他在国内太左倾了，这是可能的，但可能吗？所以如果你看看他的经济政策，那是大多数人通常最关心的，不是最引人注目的，但如果你问普通人，那是面包和黄油的问题。
The economy grew every year in Kennedy's administration. And the one big thing he did was to cut everybody's taxes. So the economy had stuttered a bit at the end of Eisenhower's time. There'd been a brief recession in the late 50s. And Kennedy's keen to get it started again. Now, he could do this through Roosevelt-type big government public works, or he could cut taxes and give people more money to spend. The Liz Truss option. The Liz Truss option. That's not a comparison you often hear, is it? The Kennedy-Truss comparison. But it works for JFK. It does work for JFK, and he lasts longer than Liz Truss.
肯尼迪政府期间经济每年都在增长。他做的一件大事是削减每个人的税收。所以经济在艾森豪威尔时代末期有点停滞。50年代末曾有过短暂的衰退。肯尼迪渴望让它重新开始。现在，他可以通过罗斯福式的大政府公共工程来做到这一点，或者他可以减税，给人们更多的钱去消费。利兹·特拉斯选项。利兹·特拉斯选项。这不是你经常听到的比较，是吗？肯尼迪-特拉斯比较。但这对肯尼迪有效。它确实对肯尼迪有效，而且他比利兹·特拉斯任期更长。
So he cut most tax bans. There are about a thousand different tax bans in America in the early 60s. The average cut was about 20%. So if you were the top rate taxpayer, so the people who might be in a shadowy meeting, Tom. Yes. Smoking cigars. Yeah. Deciding to rub him out. You have JFK to thank for slashing your rate of tax from 90% to 70%. So whether such people are genuinely suffused with rage against JFK's socialistic policies, I will leave the listener to decide for themselves. And in fact, some liberals, it's often a thing among liberal historians, they will say, JFK is just an establishment
所以他削减了大多数税级。60年代初美国大约有一千个不同的税级。平均削减幅度约为20%。所以如果你是最高税率纳税人，也就是那些可能在阴暗会议上的人，汤姆。是的。抽着雪茄。是的。决定干掉他。你得感谢肯尼迪将你的税率从90%削减到70%。所以这些人是否真的对肯尼迪的社会主义政策充满愤怒，我将留给听众自己决定。事实上，一些自由派，这在自由派历史学家中很常见，他们会说，肯尼迪只是一个建制派
centrist dad. He's not actually doing all the things that he should be doing. So there's that. Okay. On the centrist daddery, of course, the great domestic talking point, the thing that's roiling America is the civil rights movement. So we did an episode, didn't we, on Martin Luther King's great speech in 1962. And you talked there about how Kennedy was kind of a bit ambivalent about civil rights, was he? Is that unfair? To a degree. If Kennedy unusually had decided to spend late nights at the White House, not with some imported secretary that his aides had brought in for the occasion, but with you,
中间派老爸。他实际上并没有做他应该做的所有事情。所以就是这样。好的。关于中间派老爸，当然，伟大的国内话题，搅动美国的事情是民权运动。所以我们做了一集，不是吗，关于马丁·路德·金1962年的伟大演讲。你在那里谈到了肯尼迪对民权有点矛盾，是吗？这不公平吗？在某种程度上。如果肯尼迪不寻常地决定在白宫熬夜，不是和助手们带来的进口秘书，而是和你，
Tom, he would say to you, I do care about civil rights. I think it's a disgrace that people are treated so badly in the South. Of course, it's a long, deep problem that's been going on for generations. I would hate it if I lived there. But he would see it in quite academic terms. He'd see it as a policy issue. How do we solve this? And is that firstly, because he's looking at it as someone who wants to win re-election? Of course. And doesn't want to alienate white democratic voters in the South? And secondly, is it because he doesn't have much personal experience of what it means for segregated black people in the South
汤姆，他会告诉你，我确实关心民权。我认为人们在南方受到如此恶劣的对待是一种耻辱。当然，这是一个长期、深刻的问题，已经持续了几代人。如果我住在那里，我会讨厌它。但他会以相当学术的术语来看待它。他会把它看作一个政策问题。我们如何解决这个问题？首先，这是因为他是一个想赢得连任的人吗？当然。并且不想疏远南方的白人民主党选民？其次，这是因为他没有太多关于南方被隔离的黑人意味着什么的个人经验
to be denied the vote and attacked with dogs and denied basic rights. Absolutely, absolutely right on both counts. So on the one hand, he's grown up in gilded splendor in Massachusetts and been going around to London and going on trips to Europe and hobnobbing with actresses and all that stuff. He spent far more time in Europe than he has ever spent in the American South. I mean, he spent probably more time in one city, London, than most of the American South put together. To him, he doesn't have black friends. There weren't black people at Choate, or would there have been people at Harvard?
被剥夺投票权，被狗攻击，被剥夺基本权利。绝对，绝对两点都对。所以一方面，他在马萨诸塞州金碧辉煌地长大，去过伦敦，去过欧洲旅行，与女演员交际等等。他在欧洲花的时间比他在美国南方花的时间多得多。我的意思是，他在一个城市，伦敦，花的时间可能比整个美国南方加起来还要多。对他来说，他没有黑人朋友。乔特中学没有黑人，或者哈佛会有吗？
Not that he would have associated with. It's just never been an issue for him. So there's no emotional investment. One of the things I remember from the episode that we did on the Martin Luther King speech is that Kennedy had never heard Martin Luther King speak before. No, exactly. That's his first time he hears him. Yeah. And then there's the issue of the coalition, that to get anything through Congress, he'll probably need to depend on Southern Democratic votes.
不是他会交往的那种。这对他来说从来不是一个问题。所以没有情感投入。我记得我们在马丁·路德·金演讲那集里的一件事是，肯尼迪以前从未听过马丁·路德·金演讲。不，完全正确。那是他第一次听他演讲。是的。然后是联盟的问题，为了在国会通过任何事情，他可能需要依赖南方民主党的投票。
Obviously, they will never vote for him on civil rights. So if he wants to get that through, he'll have to rely on Republican votes. He appoints his attorney general, so he's in charge of law and order, his younger brother, Robert. Robert at this stage, he's a fascinating character actually, Tom. Ends up being a great aficionado of Greek tragedy, would you believe? I'm not surprised. But Robert at this stage is a very hard man. Robert is the fixer who does the dirty work for his older brother. And he basically says to Robert, just keep me out of civil rights. Keep it quiet.
显然，他们永远不会在民权问题上投票给他。所以如果他想通过那个，他将不得不依赖共和党人的投票。他任命了他的司法部长，所以他负责法律和秩序，他的弟弟罗伯特。罗伯特在这个阶段，他实际上是一个迷人的人物，汤姆。最终成为希腊悲剧的伟大爱好者，你相信吗？我不惊讶。但罗伯特在这个阶段是一个非常强硬的人。罗伯特是为他哥哥做脏活的修理工。他基本上对罗伯特说，让我远离民权。保持安静。
We can deal with that in the second term. I don't need any grief about civil rights. And actually what happens, of course, is that civil rights becomes this colossal issue. And a couple of occasions, he has to federalize the National Guard, send in the National Guard over the heads of state governors to enforce the desegregation of universities, send in the National Guard over the heads of state governors to enforce the desegregation of universities, first in Mississippi in 1962 and then in Alabama in 1963. So circumstances are pushing him to take a more and more interventionist line on civil rights. And then in June 1963, he finally realizes he has to bite the bullet. He gives a landmark TV speech, actually a really
我们可以在第二任期处理这个问题。我不需要任何关于民权的悲伤。当然，实际上发生的事情是，民权成为了一个巨大的问题。有几次，他不得不联邦化国民警卫队，越过州长派遣国民警卫队，以强制执行大学的种族隔离，越过州长派遣国民警卫队，以强制执行大学的种族隔离，第一次是在1962年的密西西比州，然后是1963年的阿拉巴马州。所以环境正在推动他采取越来越干预的民权路线。然后在1963年6月，他终于意识到他必须咬紧牙关。他发表了一次具有里程碑意义的电视演讲，实际上是一个非常
powerful speech, in which he says, this is a moral issue as old as the scriptures and as clear as the American constitution. He says, we preach freedom around the world, but how can we do that when we say we are the land of the free except for the Negroes? We have no second-class citizens except for Negroes. We have no class or caste system, no ghettos, no master race except with respect to Negroes. And he also says, who among us, if we were black, would be content with the councils of patience and delay? So he says, okay, enough. Let's fix it. And he says, I'm going to send to Congress a bill to outlaw discrimination in schools and public accommodations and employment to end the age of discrimination. The issue he has is, is he going to be able to get this through Congress? And at that point in
有力的演讲，他在其中说，这是一个像经文一样古老，像美国宪法一样清晰的道德问题。他说，我们在世界各地宣扬自由，但当我们说我们是自由之地，除了黑人之外，我们怎么能这样做呢？除了黑人，我们没有二等公民。我们没有阶级或种姓制度，没有贫民窟，没有主宰种族，除了针对黑人。他还说，我们中间，如果我们是黑人，谁会满足于耐心和拖延的建议？所以他说，好吧，够了。让我们解决它。他说，我将向国会提交一项法案，取缔学校、公共场所和就业中的歧视，结束歧视时代。他面临的问题是，他能让它在国会通过吗？而在那个时候，在
the summer of 1963, it looks very unlikely. It looks like the Southern Democrats will block it. So he's been pushed into taking this position. And lots of black civil rights leaders say he's been very slow. He's dragged his feet. But at last, he's given us the speech we dreamed of from a president. But whether he can turn that into legislative accomplishment, that's a very different question. So presumably that is something that he would, now having made this speech, he has to look to sell it to people in the South and to cities like Dallas in Texas. So that's Kennedy's domestic policies. But let's take a break now. When we come back, let's look at the dimension of foreign policy, Cuba, missile crises, and the Cold War. So we'll be back in a few minutes. Add free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets. Head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
1963年夏天，这看起来不太可能。看起来南方民主党人会阻止它。所以他被推到了这个立场。许多黑人民权领袖说他非常缓慢。他拖拖拉拉。但终于，他给了我们梦想中总统的演讲。但他能否将其转化为立法成就，那是一个非常不同的问题。所以大概这就是他会做的事情，现在发表了这个演讲，他必须设法把它卖给南方的人们和德克萨斯州达拉斯这样的城市。所以这就是肯尼迪的国内政策。但让我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看外交政策、古巴、导弹危机和冷战的维度。所以我们几分钟后回来。无广告收听，加更剧集和抢先获得现场门票。前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And we are looking at the presidency of JFK. And Dominic, in the first half, we, well, you, to be honest, gave us a survey of his domestic record. But as we said, his real focus, the events that he's really remembered for, are all pretty much in the dimension of foreign policy, aren't they? They are, because that's what had fascinated him since he was a teenager. In the first episode, we talked about him reading Winston Churchill's book, The World Crisis. He read a biography of Duke of Marlborough. He had written his thesis about British politics in the 1930s.
你好，欢迎回到《历史余味》。我们正在审视肯尼迪的总统任期。多米尼克，在上半场，我们，嗯，老实说，你给了我们一份他国内记录的调查。但正如我们所说，他真正的焦点，他真正被记住的事件，几乎都在外交政策的维度上，不是吗？它们是，因为那是他十几岁以来就让他着迷的东西。在第一集中，我们谈到了他阅读温斯顿·丘吉尔的书《世界危机》。他读了马尔博罗公爵的传记。他写了关于1930年代英国政治的论文。
But what those things had in common was they're all really about foreign affairs and kind of international relations. And that's what fascinates him. Presumably, it's not just that he's kind of, oh, I can't be bothered with the domestic sphere. I mean, foreign policy is intruding on him, isn't it? Because he has this huge problem that there is a communist outpost in the form of Cuba right on America's doorstep. Yes. And don't forget, he's come to
但这些事情的共同点是，它们实际上都是关于外交事务和国际关系之类的。这就是让他着迷的地方。大概，不仅仅是他，哦，我不能被国内领域所困扰。我的意思是，外交政策正在侵入他，不是吗？因为他有一个巨大的问题，那就是在美国家门口有一个以古巴形式存在的共产主义前哨。是的。而且别忘了，他来到
office proclaiming, we will pay any price, bear any burden in the defense of liberty, all this kind of crusading rhetoric. He believes in the Cold War. Kennedy is more nuanced than just to say, he's anti-communist, of course, but he's been very conscious in the 50s because he has been to places like Indochina, he's been to Vietnam. He has seen the difficulty of what happens when a European empire withdraws and then someone's going to fill the gap and there's a competition. Is it going to be communists or anti-communists? What's the United States going to do? He's very conscious that the United States can't just be the bully and can't be the sponsor always of the most repressive conservative forces in society.
办公室宣称，我们将付出任何代价，承担任何负担来捍卫自由，所有这些十字军式的修辞。他相信冷战。肯尼迪比仅仅说他是反共的要微妙得多，当然，但他50年代一直非常清醒，因为他去过像印度支那这样的地方，他去过越南。他看到了当一个欧洲帝国撤退，然后有人要填补空白，并且存在竞争时会发生什么困难。是共产主义者还是反共产主义者？美国要怎么做？他非常清醒地意识到，美国不能仅仅是恶霸，也不能总是社会中最压迫、最保守力量的赞助者。
So he's kind of wrestling with that. But Cuba is a particularly incendiary problem because it's right on America's doorstep. A lot of Americans have lost money because of the Cuban Revolution. A lot of Cuban exiles have ended up in Florida and Miami and are pressing for action. And when he comes in, he is briefed within days, I think, by the CIA that they have been planning an operation to retake Cuba. They've been planning it for a year. They have a scheme of basically getting Cuban exiles, getting paramilitaries, and transporting them from Central America to Cuba, and giving them air support with bombers under CIA command, and that they think there is enough of a groundswell of anti-Castro feeling in Cuba that they will be able to topple Castro.
所以他对此感到有些纠结。但古巴是一个特别棘手的问题，因为它就在美国的家门口。许多美国人因为古巴革命而损失了金钱。许多古巴流亡者最终来到了佛罗里达和迈阿密，并一直在施压要求采取行动。当他上任时，我想他在几天内就收到了中央情报局的简报，称他们一直在策划一项夺回古巴的行动。他们已经策划了一年。他们的计划基本上是召集古巴流亡者，组织准军事部队，将他们从中美洲运送到古巴，并在中央情报局的指挥下用轰炸机为他们提供空中支援，他们认为古巴国内有足够的反卡斯特罗情绪，足以推翻卡斯特罗。
And I mean, if this goes ahead, it'd be a great coup for Kennedy. Literally. Yeah, it'd be a great coup for kennedy literally yeah it will be a great coup yeah very good now straight away some of kennedy's aides think this sounds kind of far-fetched like 1500 people is not many because these are the same guys who are giving castro exploding cigars and well they're not doing that at this stage. Oh, have they not? Okay. They're later on going to be the exploding cigars. Making his hair fall out. Right, the beard falling out powder and so on. These are very much the plan B.
我的意思是，如果这事成功了，对肯尼迪来说将是一次伟大的政变。字面意义上的。是的，这对肯尼迪来说确实是一次伟大的政变，是的，这会是一次伟大的政变，非常好。现在，肯尼迪的一些助手立刻觉得这听起来有点牵强，比如1500人并不多，因为这些人就是那些给卡斯特罗提供爆炸雪茄的家伙，好吧，他们在这个阶段还没做那件事。哦，他们还没做吗？好吧。他们后来才会搞出爆炸雪茄。让他的头发掉光。对，让胡子掉光的粉末等等。这些确实是B计划。
So the plan A is the day of pigs. And at the time, some of Kennedy's aides, well, they clearly have doubts. But the general mood, and you see this again with Vietnam years later, the general mood is we should look strong. We should do things. We're the United States. Let's give it a go. What could possibly go wrong? So in April 1961, they launched the Bear Pigs operation. Now, I think the CIA always thought that basically they could blackmail Kennedy. If things went wrong, he would have no choice but to send in lots of support, authorize more airstrikes, all this kind of thing. And actually what happens is the whole thing is pretty much done and dusted in about three days. The guys land. Cuba doesn't
所以A计划是猪湾事件。当时，肯尼迪的一些助手显然有疑虑。但总体氛围，就像多年后你在越南问题上看到的那样，总体氛围是我们应该表现得强硬。我们应该采取行动。我们是美国。让我们试一试。能出什么差错呢？所以1961年4月，他们发起了猪湾行动。现在，我认为中央情报局一直认为他们基本上可以勒索肯尼迪。如果事情出了差错，他将别无选择，只能派遣大量支援，授权更多的空袭，诸如此类的事情。而实际上发生的情况是，整个事情在三天内就基本结束了。这些人登陆了。古巴并没有
rise as they hoped. They basically end up either being killed or captured by Castro's troops. And JFK, when people say to him, will you send more air support? He says, no, this is obviously a disaster. Why would I bother? No. Also, he doesn't want to get sucked into this flashpoint that could cause problems with the Soviet Union, with Cuba's communist sponsor. So the Bay of Pigs is a disaster. And there's no doubt that among some Cuban exiles, they blame Kennedy. And there's a lot of bitterness. They think he let them down. You know, it was a pretty stupid operation to begin with.
像他们希望的那样起义。他们基本上要么被杀，要么被卡斯特罗的军队俘虏。当人们问肯尼迪是否会派遣更多空中支援时，他说，不，这显然是一场灾难。我为什么要费那个劲？不。而且，他不想被卷入这个可能导致与苏联（古巴的共产主义赞助国）产生问题的冲突点。所以猪湾事件是一场灾难。毫无疑问，一些古巴流亡者责怪肯尼迪。而且有很多怨恨。他们认为他辜负了他们。你知道，这从一开始就是一个相当愚蠢的行动。
Kennedy hasn't given up on the idea of getting rid of Castro. So this thing called Operation Mongoose, Tom, which is your exploding cigars, seashells planted that will explode when he picks them up, all these kinds of things. It's sometimes claimed, I think, in a lot of histories that this is Kennedy's personal obsession, that when he wakes up in the morning, he's thinking about exploding cigars. Because it's quite Churchill, isn't it? It's the kind of thing Churchill would have loved. It is. Mad schemes. Yes, it is a mad scheme. Exploding gizmos. So is he influenced by that at all or not? You see, I don't think actually Kennedy is quite as into this as everybody thinks he is. I think
肯尼迪并没有放弃除掉卡斯特罗的想法。所以这个叫“猫鼬行动”的东西，汤姆，就是你说的爆炸雪茄、埋在沙滩里他一捡起来就会爆炸的贝壳，所有这些东西。我认为在很多历史记载中，有时有人声称这是肯尼迪个人的执念，他早上醒来时想的就是爆炸雪茄。因为这很像丘吉尔，不是吗？这是丘吉尔会喜欢的那种东西。确实是。疯狂的计划。是的，这是一个疯狂的计划。爆炸的小玩意。那么他受此影响了吗？你看，我其实并不认为肯尼迪像大家想的那样沉迷于此。我认为
it's become conventional wisdom that the Canada is thought of nothing else but murdering Fidel Castro. I think when it comes up in meetings, Kennedy says, sure, go for it. But I don't think when he's off with the latest secretary, I don't think this is what's playing on his mind. Damn you, Castro. Yeah. Yes. Is that what he's saying yeah yeah i think it's annoying that castro is still there but i don't think he's obsessed by it as we are now with it if you know what i mean because presumably his real focus is with the soviet union yes of course absolutely it is the guy who's written who wrote that essay about francois the
这已经成了公认的看法，认为肯尼迪满脑子想的都是谋杀菲德尔·卡斯特罗。我认为当会议上提到这件事时，肯尼迪会说，当然，去做吧。但我不认为当他与最新的秘书在一起时，这是他脑子里想的事情。该死的卡斯特罗。是的。是的，这就是他说的吗？是的，我想卡斯特罗还在那里让他很烦，但我并不认为他像我们现在这样对此着迷，如果你明白我的意思的话，因为大概他真正的焦点是苏联。是的，当然，绝对是。就是那个写了关于法国弗朗索瓦一世文章的家伙。
first of france yeah this is his field of the cloth of gold or something going off to meet khrushchev and all that he thinks of himself as a big player and castro is just an irritation Francois I of France. Yeah. This is his field of the cloth of gold or something, going off to meet Christophe and all that. He thinks of himself as a big player, and Castro is just an irritation. Yeah. How conscious is he of the shadow of the mushroom cloud? Oh, he's very conscious of it. It's there the whole time.
弗朗索瓦一世。是的，这是他的金锦缎原野之类的东西，要去见赫鲁晓夫等等。他认为自己是一个大人物，而卡斯特罗只是一个烦恼。是的。他对蘑菇云的阴影有多清醒的认识？哦，他非常清醒。它一直都在那里。
It's absolutely there the whole time in the early 60s. And he presumably has lots of accurate briefings on what a nuclear war would mean. Oh, yeah. He undoubtedly knows what a nuclear war would mean. I mean, he doesn't want a nuclear war. And thanks in large degree to Kennedy, there isn't a nuclear war. So funny enough, the one thing that often gets missed is there could easily have been a nuclear war about Berlin. So that would be a very obvious flashpoint. He first meets Nikita Khrushchev, who's the relatively new paramount leader of the Soviet
在60年代初，它绝对一直都在那里。而且他大概收到了许多关于核战争意味着什么的准确简报。哦，是的。他无疑知道核战争意味着什么。我的意思是，他不想要核战争。在很大程度上多亏了肯尼迪，才没有发生核战争。所以有趣的是，经常被忽略的一点是，关于柏林本可能很容易发生核战争。那将是一个非常明显的冲突点。他第一次见到尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，他是苏联相对较新的最高领导人。
Union. In the summer of 1961, they go to Vienna. So this is just a couple of months after the Bay of Pigs. And he is off his face on painkillers, isn't he? Kennedy. Yeah. I remember a brilliant book by David Reynolds. Is it David Reynolds? David Reynolds, yeah. Summits. Yes, yeah.
在1961年夏天，他们去了维也纳。所以这距离猪湾事件才几个月。他当时因为止痛药而神志不清，不是吗？肯尼迪。是的。我记得大卫·雷诺兹写过一本精彩的书。是大卫·雷诺兹吗？大卫·雷诺兹，是的。峰会。是的，是的。
And the account of the summit there is amazing, that Kennedy's just shoveling painkillers. But this is true, Tom, for Kennedy throughout this period. So the reason we spent so long talking about Kennedy's back, his malaria, his urinary issues, his Addison's disease, is because in this point, if you look at photos of Kennedy as a young man, and then photos of him as president, the one thing that is so obvious is that as president, he's like somebody has puffed him up. His skin is very puffy. His eyes are narrowed. His face is kind of yellow and puffy. He's still a handsome man, but the truth is he is on a massive cocktail of drugs, often working against one another because the Addison's disease makes a mess of all the other things. And he travels
关于那次峰会的描述令人惊叹，肯尼迪一直在吞服止痛药。但汤姆，这对肯尼迪来说在整个时期都是事实。所以我们花这么长时间谈论肯尼迪的背部、疟疾、泌尿问题、阿狄森氏病的原因，是因为在这一点上，如果你看肯尼迪年轻时的照片，然后再看他当总统时的照片，最明显的一点是，作为总统，他看起来就像被人充了气一样。他的皮肤非常浮肿。他的眼睛眯着。他的脸有点发黄和浮肿。他仍然是一个英俊的男人，但事实是他正在服用大量的药物组合，这些药物往往相互抵消，因为阿狄森氏病把其他所有问题都搞乱了。他旅行时
when he goes to Vienna, for example, or when he goes to Dallas later on, he would travel with a special kind of plank, like a kind of wooden plank and all this orthopedic stuff. And he has a kind of horrid kind of corset, doesn't he? A corset that he has to wear to basically keep him upright. So him being off his face, as you put it, vienna i mean that's nothing unusual but he's often in agony actually and how do you judge his performance at vienna he does really badly in vienna i mean kennedy himself says of khrushchev he beat the hell out of me that khrushchev has gone in for a fight khrushchev said later you know i would have liked
例如当他去维也纳，或者后来去达拉斯时，他会带着一种特殊的木板，就像一种木板和所有这些矫形器材。他有一种可怕的紧身胸衣，不是吗？他必须穿的紧身胸衣，基本上是为了让他保持直立。所以他神志不清，正如你所说，维也纳，我的意思是这没什么不寻常的，但他实际上经常处于剧痛之中。你如何评价他在维也纳的表现？他在维也纳表现得很糟糕，我的意思是肯尼迪自己说赫鲁晓夫把他打得落花流水，赫鲁晓夫是去打架的。赫鲁晓夫后来曾说，你知道，我本来想
to be nice to kennedy he seemed a nice guy but but I was doing my job, which was to give him a really hard time. And he does. And they want to kind of reconcile the status of Berlin, which has obviously been divided since the Second World War. The Soviets wanted to be part of East Germany, and they basically want the West out. The West obviously don't want that at all. And Kennedy just allows himself really to be shouted at by Khrushchev. And he's really shaken
对肯尼迪好一点，他看起来是个好人，但我当时在做我的工作，那就是让他很难受。他确实做到了。他们想调和柏林的地位，自二战以来柏林显然一直处于分裂状态。苏联人希望它成为东德的一部分，他们基本上希望西方离开。西方显然根本不希望那样。而肯尼迪真的只是任由赫鲁晓夫对他大喊大叫。他真的很震惊
when he comes away because he hasn't done himself justice somebody who's so used to being the alpha male and actually he's used to people falling for his charm and finding him funny and great company and Khrushchev's not interested in any of that and Kennedy finds that very troubling and then just two months later Khrushchev moves in Berlin. We did the episode, Tom, about the Berlin Wall with Ian McGregor, a wonderful guest, great episode. The Berlin Wall goes up. Now, that is a moment that a different president could have overreacted to. And Kennedy protests, but he does nothing about it, really.
当他离开时，因为他没有发挥出自己的水平，作为一个习惯于成为阿尔法男性的人，实际上他习惯于人们被他的魅力所吸引，觉得他风趣且是很好的伙伴，而赫鲁晓夫对这些一点也不感兴趣，肯尼迪觉得这非常令人不安。然后仅仅两个月后，赫鲁晓夫就在柏林采取了行动。汤姆，我们和伊恩·麦格雷戈做过关于柏林墙的那一期节目，一位很棒的嘉宾，很棒的一期。柏林墙建起来了。现在，那是一个不同的总统可能会反应过度的时刻。肯尼迪抗议了，但他真的什么也没做。
He sends troops to the checkpoint. The tanks squaring up. The tanks, the footage and the photos, it's extraordinary. That could be the beginning of the Third World War. But Kennedy is very conscious, you know, we won't do anything to provoke them because actually in some ways, the forced partition of Berlin with the erection of the wall, it's not a bad outcome from his point of view. I mean, aside from anything else, it's a terrible symbol of what the Cold War means. Yes, but it freezes the conflict. I mean, if there's a bloody big war there, then you can't fight each other.
他派军队去了检查站。坦克对峙。坦克，那些镜头和照片，真是非同寻常。那可能是第三次世界大战的开始。但肯尼迪非常有意识，你知道，我们不会做任何挑衅他们的事，因为实际上在某些方面，柏林被迫分裂并竖起围墙，从他的角度来看，这并不是一个坏结果。我的意思是，撇开其他不谈，这是冷战意味着什么的糟糕象征。是的，但它冻结了冲突。我的意思是，如果那里发生了一场血腥的大战，那么你们就无法互相争斗了。
So how would you gauge his performance in that, that he's kind of Goldilocks, tough, but he's reacting in a fairly sensible way. He's not escalating things. He's not overreacted to the provocation in Berlin. And that's actually the pattern that you will see in the second year with the great event of the second year, which is the Cuban Missile Crisis. So that really is, even if you're a Kennedy skeptic, even if you say he is a spoiled brat and he's entitled and they're making excuses for the womanizing and he's just a rich man's David Cameron. Even if you said all that, I think his performance in the Cuban Missile Crisis is pretty good because he gets these photos on the 16th of June, 1962. The missiles are being installed, Soviet missiles in Cuba, and that clearly can reach the American
那么你如何评价他在那件事上的表现，他有点像金发姑娘，强硬，但他以一种相当理智的方式做出反应。他没有升级事态。他没有对柏林的挑衅反应过度。这实际上是你会在第二年看到的那种模式，第二年的重大事件，即古巴导弹危机。所以这确实是，即使你是一个肯尼迪怀疑论者，即使你说他是一个被宠坏的顽童，他有权有势，他们为他的风流韵事找借口，他只是一个富人的大卫·卡梅伦。即使你说了所有这些，我认为他在古巴导弹危机中的表现也相当不错，因为他在1962年6月16日得到了这些照片。导弹正在安装，苏联在古巴的导弹，这显然可以到达美国
mainland. And this is a massive deal. I mean, this puts America itself under threat. And of course, Kennedy's always a politician. So if news of this gets out, he can't just do nothing. Because if news got out that he knew about it and did nothing, he would make him look so weak, especially after what had happened in Berlin. So he doesn't do what maybe Nixon would have done nixon is a great man for brooding you know darkened rooms classical music playing staring into the fireplace and thinking about how miserable he is and how uncool he is kennedy doesn't do any of that and he doesn't sort of secrete himself away
本土。这是一件大事。我的意思是，这使美国本身受到威胁。当然，肯尼迪总是一个政治家。所以如果这个消息传出去，他不能什么都不做。因为如果消息传出他知道这件事却什么都没做，那会让他看起来非常软弱，尤其是在柏林发生的事情之后。所以他没有做尼克松可能做的事，尼克松是一个非常喜欢沉思的人，你知道，在黑暗的房间里，放着古典音乐，盯着壁炉，思考着他是多么悲惨，他是多么不酷。肯尼迪没有做任何这些，他也没有把自己藏起来
with henry kissinger and cook up some scheme he convenes this big kind of committee it's called the x-com and with generals and advisors and they're all sworn to secrecy and his brother and his brother robert who's a really big player in this i mean somebody that as we said before is very happy to be his hard man and to argue with everybody on kennedy's behalf and you know push the generals and all this kind of thing and kennedy just sits there he's obviously always present in the discussions we know from the tapes and the transcripts that he's an active participant. But he's weighing up all the different options. Because some of those generals, I mean, the most famous one is a guy called General Curtis
和亨利·基辛格一起策划什么阴谋，他召集了这个大型委员会，叫X委员会，有将军和顾问，他们都宣誓保密，还有他的兄弟，他的兄弟罗伯特，他在其中是一个非常重要的人物，我的意思是，正如我们之前所说，他非常乐意成为他的硬汉，代表肯尼迪与所有人争论，你知道，推动将军们等等。肯尼迪只是坐在那里，他显然总是出现在讨论中，我们从录音带和记录中知道他是一个积极的参与者。但他正在权衡所有不同的选择。因为那些将军中的一些人，我的意思是，最著名的一个叫柯蒂斯·勒梅将军
LeMay. He would love to get going. Have a crack at the commies. Let's have a crack at the commies. You know, they think that if at the end of all this, there's one Russian left and two Americans, then we've won. Yeah. And that's a great result.
他很想开始行动。给共产党人一点颜色看看。让我们给共产党人一点颜色看看。你知道，他们认为如果这一切结束时，剩下一个俄罗斯人和两个美国人，那么我们就赢了。是的。那是一个伟大的结果。
Yeah. And he's very conscious. He's been in war. He didn't enjoy it. He came back from war a weakened man, sickly man. He is very conscious of the costs the whole time. So we know that in all these discussions, I mean, all the people who've studied them, the historians, Max Hastings and so on, Fred Logevold, say he is judicious, he's careful, he says, let's not rush. And so the stakes are very high for himself personally, for his administration, for the United States. Is he thinking the stakes are global? This could be the end of humanity. Of course he is. Of course he is. Yeah, we absolutely know that, you know, the mood in these meetings is funereal, is really somber. We're in an impossible position
是的。而且他非常有意识。他经历过战争。他并不享受它。他从战争中回来时是一个虚弱的人，多病的人。他一直非常有意识地意识到代价。所以我们知道在所有这些讨论中，我的意思是，所有研究过这些的人，历史学家，马克斯·黑斯廷斯等等，弗雷德·洛格瓦尔，都说他很审慎，他很小心，他说，我们不要急。所以对他个人、他的政府、美国来说，赌注非常高。他是否认为赌注是全球性的？这可能是人类的终结。当然他是。当然他是。是的，我们绝对知道，你知道，这些会议的气氛是葬礼般的，非常阴沉。我们处于一个不可能的境地
here. We have to do something. We can't not do anything, but we're very conscious that if we do this wrong, you know, the human race could be ravaged beyond imagination. Whoops, apocalypse. Exactly. Absolutely. Exactly. So they impose a blockade. They don't act immediately against the missiles. They don't do what some of the generals want,
在这里。我们必须做点什么。我们不能什么都不做，但我们非常清楚，如果我们做错了，你知道，人类可能会遭受无法想象的蹂躏。哎呀，世界末日。正是如此。绝对是。正是如此。所以他们实施了封锁。他们没有立即对导弹采取行动。他们没有做一些将军想要做的事情，
which is to strike at Cuba straight away. He says, well, have a naval blockade around Cuba. I mean, this is a great subject for at least one Restless History podcast. But just to tell the story
那就是立即打击古巴。他说，好吧，在古巴周围进行海军封锁。我的意思是，这是一个至少可以做一期《Restless History》播客的好题材。但只是为了快速讲完这个故事
very quickly, they impose the blockade. The Soviets look like they're going to ignore it and they have a ship steaming towards the islands. The world holds its breath, Tom. I know you love a BBC Two documentary cliche. I do.
很快，他们实施了封锁。苏联人看起来要无视它，他们有一艘船正向岛屿驶去。世界屏住了呼吸，汤姆。我知道你喜欢BBC二台纪录片的陈词滥调。我喜欢。
The world holds its breath. And then Khrushchev sends two messages, the first of which seems to be quite emollient, the second of which seems to be quite belligerent. And Kennedy says, let's pretend the second one never happened. Maybe he sent that into duress or been drinking or whatever. Let's reply to the first message and let's do quietly a little deal. They will withdraw their missiles from Cuba and we will withdraw our missiles from Turkey, which is obviously on the border of the Soviet Union. So they will feel that they have got something out of it.
世界屏住了呼吸。然后赫鲁晓夫发了两条信息，第一条似乎相当温和，第二条似乎相当好战。肯尼迪说，让我们假装第二条从未发生过。也许他是被迫发送的，或者喝醉了什么的。让我们回复第一条信息，让我们悄悄地做一个小交易。他们将从古巴撤走导弹，我们将从土耳其撤走导弹，土耳其显然在苏联边境。所以他们会觉得他们从中得到了一些东西。
And that's what they do. So, Dominic. Yeah. Khrushchev blinks. When it's perceived as Khrushchev blinking, it's a tiny bit more ambiguous than that, because Khrushchev has got the removal of the American missiles from Turkey out of it. So he has got something. But in the world's press, because of this image of the Soviet ship steaming towards Cuba and then going back.
这就是他们所做的。所以，多米尼克。是的。赫鲁晓夫眨眼了。当它被视为赫鲁晓夫眨眼时，它比那稍微模糊一点，因为赫鲁晓夫从中得到了美国从土耳其撤走导弹的结果。所以他确实得到了一些东西。但在世界媒体上，因为苏联船只驶向古巴然后返回的这种形象。
And then going back, it looks as if Khrushchev has blinked. Good optics. It's bad optics for Khrushchev, who then gets the boot in Moscow. Not just because of that, but also because he's been kind of very unreliable and eccentric. And Kennedy comes out of it looking the person who held his nerve and won the day. Young, charismatic. And Kennedy comes out of it looking the person who held his nerve and won the day. Young, charismatic. The amazing thing is that during all this, amid all the stress he was still carrying on,
然后返回，看起来好像是赫鲁晓夫眨眼了。好的视觉效果。这对赫鲁晓夫来说是糟糕的视觉效果，他随后在莫斯科被解职。不仅仅是因为那个，还因为他一直非常不可靠和古怪。而肯尼迪从中走出来，看起来是一个保持冷静并赢得胜利的人。年轻，有魅力。肯尼迪从中走出来，看起来是一个保持冷静并赢得胜利的人。年轻，有魅力。令人惊奇的是，在这一切期间，在所有压力中，他仍然在继续，
having a mistress called Mimi Beardsley smuggled into the White House for trysts. Well, I suppose if you think the world's going to end. Yeah, get on with it. Yeah, crack on. Yes, exactly. Could be the last chance you have. Now, there is one other thing. So on all this, Tom, on the foreign policy, because we mustn't forget we're thinking about motives
让一个叫咪咪·比尔兹利的秘密情妇被偷运进白宫幽会。好吧，我想如果你认为世界要结束了。是的，继续吧。是的，干吧。是的，正是如此。可能是你最后的机会了。现在，还有一件事。所以关于这一切，汤姆，关于外交政策，因为我们不能忘记我们正在考虑动机
to bump Kennedy off. You can see why anti-Castro Cuban exiles would be very, very cross with Kennedy. You can actually see why, you know, if a Cuban exile had been caught red-handed with a revolver in his hand, having shot Kennedy in the White House. You wouldn't be surprised. I mean, it's not inherently implausible. On the missile crisis, on his handling of affairs with the Soviet Union, he's definitely not weak. I mean, he's not an appeaser like his father had been. So what do the generals make of him in the wake of the missile crisis? Do they kind of express their respect or are there some who think? I mean, there'll be one or two who grumble, but I think most of them recognise that he's done a decent job. There's no General Pinochet waiting in the wings at the Pentagon or anything.
干掉肯尼迪。你可以看出为什么反卡斯特罗的古巴流亡者会非常非常生肯尼迪的气。你实际上可以看出为什么，你知道，如果一个古巴流亡者被当场抓获，手里拿着左轮手枪，在白宫射杀了肯尼迪。你不会感到惊讶。我的意思是，这并非本质上不可信。关于导弹危机，关于他处理与苏联事务的方式，他绝对不软弱。我的意思是，他不像他父亲那样是一个绥靖主义者。那么将军们在导弹危机后对他有什么看法？他们是否表达了他们的尊重，还是有一些人认为？我的意思是，会有一两个抱怨的人，但我认为他们大多数人认识到他做得不错。五角大楼里没有什么皮诺切特将军在等待时机之类的东西。
Now, the other big thing is Vietnam. So when I saw that Oliver Stone film, JFK, which we talked about in episode one, I remember really vividly how Vietnam absolutely hangs over that whole film. And the idea that Kennedy is going to withdraw from Vietnam, and that's why he was murdered. And that is, put it this way, I think it is hard to sustain that claim with any authority when you look at Kennedy's record in Vietnam.
现在，另一件大事是越南。所以当我看到那部奥利弗·斯通的电影《刺杀肯尼迪》时，我们在第一集谈到过，我非常生动地记得越南是如何绝对笼罩着整部电影的。以及肯尼迪将从越南撤军，这就是他被谋杀的原因。而且，这样说吧，我认为当你审视肯尼迪在越南的记录时，很难有任何权威性地支持这一主张。
So the United States has already committed to Vietnam before he becomes president, but not by masses of people. It's really just the military advisors level at that stage? Yeah. So there are military advisors. There's maybe something like a thousand when he comes in. He increases them quite radically in his first three years. So there's about 16,000 by late 1963. Now, don't forget there's lots of American troops and advisors in different parts of the world. So this doesn't make Vietnam a complete outlier. He is conscious that the Viet Cong, the National Liberation Front, the North Vietnamese, have been pushing and pushing since about 1961. They are trying to strengthen their grip in the countryside.
所以美国在肯尼迪成为总统之前就已经致力于越南了，但不是因为大量的人员。那个阶段真的只是军事顾问级别吗？是的。所以有军事顾问。当他上任时，可能有一千人左右。他在前三年里非常激进地增加了他们的人数。所以到1963年底大约有16,000人。现在，别忘了世界各地有很多美国军队和顾问。所以这并没有使越南成为一个完全的异类。他意识到越共、民族解放阵线、北越人自1961年左右以来一直在不断施压。他们正试图加强对农村的控制。
Their dream is to unify North Vietnam, which is communist, South Vietnam, which is anti-communist. But there are loads of examples of Kennedy saying to people, I'm very well aware how much we're hated. I'm well aware of how much the Vietnamese people resent outside interference. I'm very worried about this. I don't want to lose South Vietnam, but equally, I don't want to see us stuck in this terrible quagmire that we can't get out of. So he's conscious of all this. Now, one development that it kind of seems uncanny given what we know is going to happen is the president of Vietnam, South Vietnam, that he's got a reasonably close relationship with, I call President Diem. He is toppled by a coup in October 1963. It's not CIA orchestrated, but it's CIA backed. So a bit like the one in Chile that we talked about.
他们的梦想是统一北越（共产主义）和南越（反共产主义）。但有很多例子表明肯尼迪对人们说，我非常清楚我们有多么被憎恨。我非常清楚越南人民有多么怨恨外部干涉。我对此非常担心。我不想失去南越，但同样，我也不想看到我们陷入这个我们无法摆脱的可怕泥潭。所以他意识到这一切。现在，一个看起来很离奇的发展，考虑到我们知道将会发生什么，是越南总统，南越总统，他与他有相当密切的关系，我称之为吴廷琰总统。他在1963年10月的一场政变中被推翻。这不是中央情报局策划的，但有中央情报局的支持。所以有点像我们谈到的智利那次。
Yeah, it would have happened anyway, even if the Americans didn't approve of it. But the Americans do say, fine, go for it. He is toppled and he is then murdered. And when Kennedy hears that Ziem has been murdered, he's very shocked. I mean, people say he's furious. He thought he was just going to be imprisoned or sent into exile or something, but he is killed. And this is just weeks before Kennedy's own death. And Kennedy is very troubled by this. And at this point, he is clearly dithering about what to do in Vietnam. Now, there's some historians who say he would probably have got out. He would have said, this is obviously a bit of a basket case. We're not going to win. Let's go home. There are others who say he wouldn't have got out. The talk of getting out was a political tool. He was using that as a way of putting pressure on the
是的，即使美国人不批准，它也会发生。但美国人确实说，好吧，去做吧。他被推翻了，然后被谋杀。当肯尼迪听说吴廷琰被谋杀时，他非常震惊。我的意思是，人们说他很愤怒。他以为他只是会被监禁或流放什么的，但他被杀了。这就在肯尼迪自己去世前几周。肯尼迪对此非常困扰。在这一点上，他显然在越南问题上犹豫不决。现在，有些历史学家说他可能会撤出。他会说，这显然有点像个烂摊子。我们赢不了。让我们回家吧。还有人说他不会撤出。谈论撤出是一个政治工具。他利用这一点作为向南越施压的一种方式，但实际上他会留下来。问题是，我们从美国在其他地方的参与中知道，比如本世纪的伊拉克和阿富汗，在这些情况下实际上有多困难。把自己从泥潭中拉出来，多米尼克。一个沼泽，我想，或者一个泥潭。一个沼泽。它们是越南的批准隐喻，任何其他隐喻都是错误的。不，但是汤姆，他显然还没有下定决心，我会说，在1963年。我们将讨论关于他被暗杀的争论。但他是如此明确地致力于从越南撤军，以至于他政府中的其他人或美国建制派中的其他人足够关心，以至于为了这个而杀了他，这可信吗？我的意思是，这是否可信，我还是留给听众去判断吧。
South Vietnamese, but actually he would have stayed. The thing is, we know from the United States' involvement in other places, let's say Iraq and Afghanistan this century, how difficult it is actually in those situations. To pull yourself out of a Korkmeyer, Dominic. A morass, I think, or a Meyer. A morass. They are the approved metaphors for Vietnam and any other is wrong. No, but Tom, he clearly hasn't made up his mind, I would say, in 1963. We will come to the argument about his assassination. But is it plausible that he is so clearly committed to withdrawing from Vietnam and that people care enough, that other people in his administration or in the American establishment care enough to have him killed because of it? I mean, whether that is plausible, again, I'll leave it for the listeners
我们会讨论的，不是吗？但你可能从我构建它的方式中看出，我不认为这非常有说服力。好的。好的。就在我们谈到他去达拉斯的原因之前。是的。太空。最后的边疆。最后的边疆。我的意思是，有很多关于外星人、罗斯威尔的偏执理论，我不知道你要去哪里，汤姆，我不得不说，我只是想知道你是否觉得这些想法有什么可信度，呃，是的，我觉得它们非常可信，你指望我对此说什么？好的，好吧，我只是把它提出来，因为那都是混合的一部分，所以等等，肯尼迪想去月球，人们说，
to determine. We will discuss, won't we? But you can probably tell from the way I've framed that, that I don't regard that as overwhelmingly convincing. Okay. Okay. Just before we come to the reasons that he goes to Dallas. Yeah. Space. The final frontier. The final frontier. I mean, there's lots of paranoid theorizing about space aliens roswell i have no idea where you're going with this tom i have to i'm just wondering whether you feel there's any uh credence in ideas that uh yeah i find them very credible what do you expect me to say to that okay well i'm just i'm just putting that out there because that's all part of the mix so hold on kennedy wants to go to the moon and people say,
我们必须阻止他去月球。他们在月球上有他们不想让人看到的东西。这都在《X档案》之类的东西里。我不记得是不是关于外星人之类的东西。所以为了跳到下周，有一个叫文森特·布格里奥西的人，他写了一本书，我把手稿寄给你了，汤姆。我知道你没读过。我知道你没读过的原因是，我知道那本书有2500页长，所以你不可能读过它，
we have to stop him getting to the moon. They've got stuff on the moon they don't want people to see. It's all in the X-Files and things. I can't remember whether it's something about aliens and stuff. So just to jump ahead to next week, there's a guy called Vincent Bugliosi, who has written a book, which I've sent you the manuscript of, Tom. I know you haven't read it. And the reason I know you haven't read it is i know that book is 2500 pages long so it's implausible that you
当你还在复习其他东西的时候，但他写了这本绝对庞大的书，审视了每一个可以想象到的暗杀理论和阴谋论，他没提到吗？我想外星人是在场的，但只是非常简短和轻蔑地提到，我认为这样说是公平的。好吧，这是我最喜欢的一个。所以无论如何，多尼，那太棒了。抱歉，我降低了基调。那是一个非常权威和学术性的叙述。
will have read it when you're also revising other things but he has written this absolutely monstrous book looking at every conceivable assassination theory and conspiracy theory did he not mention it i think aliens are present but only very briefly and dismissively i think it's fair to say. Well, it's my favorite one. So anyway, Donny, that's brilliant. Sorry, I've let the tone down. That was a very authoritative and scholarly account.
那次打断，那不是打断。那是一次干预。它与你开始播客时的基调一致，这很好。所以你把我们带回了原点。是的。好吧，很好。你的精确度是为熟练工印象准备的。所以让我们结束吧。
That interruption, it wasn't an interruption. It was an intervention. It was consistent with the tone with which you began the podcast, which is nice. So you brought us back full circle. Yeah. Well, good. With your precision is for journeymen impression. So let's just end.
显然，肯尼迪在越南所做的事情，显然，他的民权立法是否通过，这些事情都取决于选举。值得停下来谈谈这一点。我们正处于1963年秋天的末尾。明年，他将面对一位共和党人，可能是亚利桑那州参议员巴里·戈德华特，他是保守派伟大的新希望，所以他就是那个人，汤姆，我知道你喜欢这个，是的，我知道你要说什么，在你的直觉中你知道他是疯子，没错，因为口号是“在你的心中你知道他是对的”，但在你的直觉中，民主党人说“你知道，你知道，他是疯子”。他实际上是一个自由意志主义者，
Obviously, what Kennedy does in Vietnam, obviously, whether his civil rights legislation passes, these things depend on the election. And it's just worth pausing for a second to talk about that. We're at the end of the autumn of 1963. Next year, he will face a Republican, probably thezona senator barry goldwater who is the great new hope of conservatives so he is the guy tom i know you love this yes i know what you're gonna say in your guts you know he's nuts that's right because the slogan was in your heart you know he's right but in your guts the democrats said you know you know, he's nuts. He's a libertarian, actually,
戈德华特。所以他不是宗教保守派之类的。他是自由意志主义者。但在当时，他被认为是共和党可能提名的最右翼的候选人。那是那些日子。肯尼迪能打败他吗？好吧，如果我们看看民意调查和肯尼迪的支持率，肯尼迪有史以来最低的支持率是在1963年9月，那是56%。把这个放在背景中，这非常非常好。所以这在选举学上很有希望。他的平均支持率，汤姆，所以他甚至没有完成三年的总统任期。他做了两年零近11个月。他在那段时间的平均支持率是70%。这是现代美国历史上最高的。
Goldwater. So he's not a religious conservative or anything like that. He's libertarian. But at the time, he was perceived as the most right-wing candidate the Republicans could possibly nominate. Those were the days. And could Kennedy beat him? Well, if we look at the polls and Kennedy's approval ratings, the lowest approval rating Kennedy ever had was in September 1963, and that was 56%. To put that into context, that is incredibly good. So that's very cephalogically promising. His approval rating average, Tom, so he doesn't even finish three years as president. He does two years and almost 11 months. His average approval rating in that time was 70%. That is the highest
那不错，不是吗？所以说肯尼迪被美国公众视为一个极其能干、温和、令人印象深刻的政治参与者，不仅仅是暗杀后的回顾性感伤。他绝对是。而且我认为毫无疑问，如果他参选，他会赢得连任。他唯一的问题是，正如你所说，南方。他还有另一个问题，那就是在德克萨斯州，这在1960年对他非常重要，他的副总统的州，德克萨斯民主党内部在两个当地权力掮客之间存在巨大的裂痕，一位叫拉尔夫·亚伯勒的参议员，他更自由派，以及德克萨斯州州长约翰·康纳利。这是关于民权的裂痕。
in modern American history. That's not bad, is it? So it's not just retrospective sentimentalizing post the assassination to say Kennedy is perceived by the American public as an extremely competent, emollient, impressive political actor. He absolutely is. And I think there's no doubt that he would have won re-election had he stood. The only issue he has is, as you said, the South. And he has another problem, which is that in Texas, which had been so important to him in 1960, his vice president state, there is a big rift within the Texas Democratic Party between two of the local power brokers, a senator called Ralph Yarborough, who's more liberal, and the Texas state governor, John Connolly. And it's the rift over civil rights.
实际上更多的是关于个性和赞助。这是一种赞助裂痕。所以它根本不是专门关于民权的。但事实上他们处于党的不同派系，因为康纳利最终基本上成为了共和党人，这可能隐约在空气中。但这是一种宫廷政治的东西。所以肯尼迪想，我会去德克萨斯，把那件事搞定，做个小巡回。他的计划是在两天内访问五个城市，搞定它，回家，在圣诞节前宣布我在64年初的连任竞选，看看我们能不能在那之前通过民权法案，但所有其他条件相同的情况下，他认为一切都相当稳妥。他决定带杰基一起去。现在他为什么要带杰基去？因为他们实际上刚刚失去了一个孩子，帕特里克，他活了
It's actually much more about personalities and patronage. It's a kind of patronage rift. So it's not over civil rights specifically at all. But the fact that they are on different wings of the party, because Connolly ends up basically becoming a Republican, that's probably in the air vaguely. But it's a kind of court politics thing. And so Kennedy thinks, I'll go down to Texas, get that done and dusted, do a little tour. His plan is to see five cities in two days, get that done, come back home, run up to christmas announce my re-election campaign in early 64 see if we can get the civil rights bill through before then but all the other things being equal he thinks it's pretty set fair he decides he's going to go with jackie now why does he take jackie with him because they have actually just lost a child patrick who lived i
我想大约两天左右，出生时非常虚弱，后来去世了。杰基陷入了非常深度的抑郁，显然，完全可以理解且自然。助手和认识他们的人说，他们在白宫的时间，他们参加过很多奢华的晚宴等等，但有很多争吵和拌嘴，以及正常的婚姻琐事，再加上他有外遇的事实，但帕特里克的去世，他们的小男孩，让他们非常亲近，你知道她现在要和他一起去德克萨斯了，他想让她和他在一起，他想让她和他在一起，所以11月21日，他们访问了圣安东尼奥、休斯顿和沃斯堡，计划是他们将在22日巡视达拉斯，然后他们将在德克萨斯的林登·约翰逊的牧场度过晚上。所以，汤姆，这就是计划。当然，我的意思是，我讨厌称它为悬念，因为每个人都知道接下来会发生什么。但下一次，我们将看看谋杀发生的那一天，然后我们将看看各种理论和可能的罪魁祸首。当然，正如我们上次所说，谋杀之谜的事情，你就是停不下来，不是吗？
think for two days or so was born very sickly and died afterwards. And Jackie had sunk into a very deep depression, obviously, completely understandably and naturally. And aides and people who knew them said, their time in the White House, they'd had lots of glamorous dinners and all that kind of thing, but there'd been a lot of arguing and bickering and normal kind of marital stuff compounded by the fact of his affairs but the loss of patrick their little boy had brought them very close together and that's you know she was going to come with him now to texas he wanted her with him that he wants to with him so on the 21st of november they visited san antonio houston and fort worth and the plan is they will tour dallas on the 22nd and then they will spend the evening in Texas at Lyndon Johnson's ranch. And so that, Tom, is the plan. And of course, I mean, I hate to call it a cliffhanger because everybody knows what is coming next. But next time, we will look at the day of the murder, and then we will look at the various theories and the possible culprits. And of course, as we said last time, the thing with the murder mysteries, you just can't stop, can you?
你太兴奋了，想知道发生了什么。是的。你实际上可以做到这一点，不是吗，多米尼克？一些幸运的人，Restless History俱乐部的成员。金票。是的。以非常非常合理的价格入场。人们以前从未听说过这个，很多人，因为我想有很多第一次听我们节目的人。所以对于那些人，
You're just so excited to find out what happens. Yeah. And you can actually do that with this, can't you, Dominic? Some lucky people, members of the Restless History Club. The golden ticket. Yeah. Yours for very, very reasonably priced admission. People have never heard this before, a lot of people, because I imagine there's loads of people listening to us for the first time. So for those people,
我会说你必须去restishistorypod.com，你会得到令人难以置信的一系列福利和款待。我们几乎是免费赠送的，不是吗？实际上就像卡米洛特一样。气氛、魅力非常相似。所以如果你进入我们的聊天社区，这不仅仅是令人难以置信的价值。这就像杰克和杰基政权鼎盛时期卡米洛特的耀眼机智。是的。我的意思是，汤姆，实际上我们差不多就是那样。广告狂人。历史播客界的杰克和杰基。
I'll say you have to go to restishistorypod.com and you get an unbelievable range of benefits and treats. We're practically giving it away, aren't we? It's like Camelot, actually. It's very like the atmosphere, the glamour. So if you go into our chat community, it's not just incredible value. It's like the dazzling repartee of Camelot in the height of the Jack and Jackie regime. Yeah. I mean, that's pretty much what we are, Tom, actually. Mad men. The Jack and Jackie of history podcasting.
好的。所以如果这不能吸引人们加入Restless History俱乐部。我不知道什么能吸引他们。是的，什么都不能。我们下次再见。为了谋杀发生的那一天。然后我们将看看所有各种理论。我不认为我们会重温外星人理论，汤姆，我告诉你，现在不会了，好吧，我们会看到的，我的意思是你知道
Right. So if that doesn't entice people to join the Restless History Club. I don't know what will. Yeah, nothing will. And we will see you next time. For the day of the murder. And then we will be looking at all the various theories. I don't think we'll be revisiting the alien theory, Tom tom i'll tell you that now well we'll see i mean you know
好的，我们这个党派里有两个人，多米尼克，确实有，这是真的，这是真的，所以我们会看到的，所以接下来，我们有暗杀的那一天，那个可怕日子的事件，那是第三集，然后是关于谁做了这件事以及为什么的所有各种理论。俄罗斯人、中央情报局、黑手党、外星人，随便什么。我们将审视所有这些。所以无论是在这一集之后立即还是下周，我们希望很快见到你。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
okay two of us in this party dominic there are that's true it's true so we will see so coming up we've got the day of the assassination the events of that terrible day that is episode three and then all the various theories about who did it and why. Russians, CIA, mafia, aliens, whatever. We'll be looking at them all. So whether it's immediately after this episode or next week, we will hopefully see you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。